les salariés de l'usine Renault de fin
ont enfin entendu une bonne nouvelle ce
mardi midi lors de la visite du ministre
du redressement productif Arnaud
Montebourg la production de la nouvelle
Nissan Mikra dans les Yvelines des 2016
mise en place par l'accord de
compétitivité début mars permettra a
priori d'embaucher de nouveaux salariés
alors en ce qui concerne l'emploi 82000
voitures en plus sur l'usine
c'est à peu près je dirais autour d'un
millier d'emplois bon alors est-ce qu'il
y aura des embauches ou pas bah ça
dépend comment l'usine s'organise ça
dépend comment le marché européen va
évoluer ça dépend de des de du succès
des Vand de Zoé c'est ça dépend de
beaucoup de choses vu l'état actuel du
marché de l'automobile des embauches
futures ne sont pas encore possibles
Carlos gone reste évasif sur le nombre
de recrutements qui seront également
conditionnés aux ventes des cliot 3 et 4
et de la Zoe de son côté Arnaud
mondbourg en tenue de travail pour
l'occasion à marteler le retour de la
production industrielle sur le
territoire aujourd'hui la direction de
Renault de l'Alliance Renault Nissan
tient ses engagements et relocalise sur
le territoire français
des dizaines de milliers de véhicules
donc c'est un renforcement de la base
industrielle France et c'est le retour
de Renault vers made in France Nissan
produit à l'heure actuelle ce modèle en
Inde pour l'exporter en Europe avec la
fabrication du modèle japonais l'usine
de Flin dans les ivelines sera le
premier site français à assembler un de
ses
véhicules